well one unit one innovation that can I
think help the world is a world
governance of future because in now
where the UN proposed but there is not
any regulation or any good management
and we are organizing in Dakar Senegal
next me next March or make a world
conference and the governance about
energy was to turn to solar energy
because you know the world have tonight
old form of finished the wind the water
the uncritically and now it is all forms
of energy are very big in harmony but
the solar is a what we call the proper
energy and we think that to just written
creating such a energy effectively that
provide the energy need for the klinke
next year and the amount of this
capacity is about 100,000 megawatt they
can do it
and the forest so we have problems the
very big program what we could read in
war is a roll of TVs 50 meters now on
7,000 kilometres looking and and this
project is supported by the Union but
till now there is anything very
significant contribution to the
constitution of a very important for all
humanity only France now stand
I'll send soldiers to participate plenty
of financial program I stated wrapped
the financial pieces cannot find a
solution but in Africa because way over
capacity for the overflow of trainers TP
invest in the rain production about iti
would see that I stated that the highest
duty to return to Africa because they're
rented by force every system many hives
Lyceum in Senegal you generally believes
that the functions are gone there for
sure ago so I have stated that if
citizenship but those improvement is how
is if the government of nature and the
people of I said that they want to come
back to Africa we should give a connect
them to this beauty and help them as
they did for Liberia one sentence before
I began they were problem between the
net use an african-american take em from
United States but now there is very
integration between GP these people only
citizens of neither